The LCD is 2 times u minus 3 times u plus 3. Fantastic work if you figured that
one out. Again, I don't expect you to get that right on your first try, or even
maybe at all. Let's see how we do it. We know u squared minus 9 is a difference
of two perfect squares. So we can factor this as u plus 3 times u minus 3. So we
can rewrite this first fraction like this. For the second denominator we have a
common factor of 2. So we can factor that out. Now that we have factored
denominators, we can use our factor tree method. These two denominators share a
common factor of u minus 3, and the other factor for this one is u plus 3, while
the other factor for this one is positive 2. And there it is. We multiply all
these together to get 2 times u plus 3 times u minus 3, our LCD.